[Musique]
si paris cette saison avec lionel messi
remporte la ligue des champions ou du
symbolisme en terme de timing ce sera
absolument parfait et ils veulent une
fanfare d'un possible pour la coupe du
monde 2022 qui est la priorité de
l'émirat pourquoi le qatar utilise le
sport le foot plus particulièrement
comme outil de soft power ici vous
regarde en termes d'argent le faut ce
qu'on dit c'est de l'argent tu sais
c'est que dalle en fait ces pilotes donc
si vous voulez aujourd'hui être affiché
à travers tous les continents avoir une
image et en plus un an de la coupe du
monde c'est rêver pour le qatar parce
qu'on va reparler d'eux et encore pour
des raisons de manière plutôt
méliorative plutôt faible
[Musique]
allez une caresse coup de jeumont arrêté
hier en sardaigne il a été libéré et
autorisé à quitter l'italie selon son
avocat une prochaine audience doit se
tenir le 4 octobre le leader
indépendantiste est poursuivi pour son
rôle dans une tentative de sécession en
joe biden entend renforcer l'influencé
américaine dans la région ados pacifique
après laffaire à des sous marins le chef
de la maison blanche qui reçoit
aujourd'hui le quad les premiers
ministres indien australien unis pour
nous après un sommet virtuel en mars
rendez vous cette fois en personne pour
tenter à leur arrivée l'alliance face à
la chine
[Musique]
le premier ministre libanais najib
mikati à paris li a rencontré emmanuel
mâcon qui a salué le nouveau
gouvernement au liban après 13 mois de
vide politique a le nouveau dirigeant
libanais promet des réformes immédiates
un préalable à l'obtention de l'aide
financière internationale
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur arte france interpellé en
italie car les podiums en est autorisé à
quitter le pays en attendant la
prochaine audience le 4 octobre il a été
libéré donc en attendant une décision de
justice qui doit statuer sur son
extradition vers l'espagne il y
poursuivit pour sédition et détournement
de fonds publics en plus de
manifestations de soutien à son égard le
président du gouvernement régional de
catalogne perret aragonès réclament le
retrait de tous les mandats d'arrêt à
son encontre
écoutez
les événements d'hier ont montré que les
autorités espagnoles ont agi de manière
infidèle envers la justice européenne
il est également clair que cela n'aide
pas le processus de négociations
nous appelons retrait des mandats
d'arrêt européen contre le président
carlès plus des monts ont contre toutes
les personnes politiques poursuivies au
dos pour l'été car ce qui est est
aujourd'hui plus que jamais la demie
ch'ti et l'autodétermination sur la
seule solution au conflit politique
fait traction encore du premier ministre
pedro sanchez dernier estima que le
leader indépendantiste doit se soumettre
à la justice on écoute
ce qui est évident c'est que carlès push
dès monde doit se présenter et
comparaître devant la justice espagnole
je les dis aussi à barcelone lors de ma
dernière visite pendant le rendez-vous
que j'ai eu avec le président de la
généralité de catalogne
aujourd'hui plus que jamais il est
important de mettre en avant le dialogue
parce que le dialogue est la seule voie
pour que les catalans puissent se
retrouver les catalans qu'ils pensent de
manière différente mais aussi les
catalans qui n'ont pas le même avis que
les espagnols qui vivent dans d'autres
régions du pays aujourd'hui le dialogue
est plus que jamais nécessaire il a été
il ya dix ans il a été en 2017 il l'est
aujourd'hui il le sera dans le futur
les activistes climatique dans la rue ce
vendredi à travers le monde entier mais
en allemagne la tonalité elle est
particulière avec la présence de greta
solberg à berlin pour l'occasion et
selon elle les partis politiques n'en
font pas assez il s'agit donc
d'interpeller les candidats aux
législatives sur les questions
environnementales
écoutez son témoignage
[Applaudissements]
je suis ici parce que pour être honnête
je ne comprends pas très bien pourquoi
les charbonnages et autres grandes
entreprises responsables du changement
climatique ne font rien car au final il
en souffre aussi et il ne s'agit pas de
la planète car la planète se régénère à
la fin de la journée c'est l'humanité
que nous conduisons
malheureusement c'est toujours pareil et
la politique ne fait rien mais je pense
qu'il est particulièrement important
d'envoyer un signal aujourd'hui avant
les élections fédérales qui ont lieu
dimanche et j'espère que de nombreuses
personnes plus âgées réfléchirons à
nouveau à la façon dont elles voteront
lorsqu'elle voit combien de jeunes sont
inquiets pour l'avenir il s'est passé
trop peu de chose en politique ces
derniers temps et la prochaines
élections qui approchent maintenant sera
aussi une élection climatiques en
particulier pour la génération qui peut
voter pour la première fois c'est
pourquoi nous voulons attirer à nouveau
l'attention et donner l'exemple
juste avant les élections afin de
pouvoir peut-être les influencer un peu
alors que la jeunesse allemande décide
pour le climat la chancelière elle
choisit à la stabilité angela merkel
appellent d'ailleurs à voter pour celui
qui représente son parti la cdu armin
laschet temps garant à 2 sa politique
avant les élections de dimanche qui
promettent un duel serré entre le favori
des sondages le social démocrate olaf
scholz et son rival de droite cette
élection elle marquera la fin de ses
années de pouvoir pour la chancelière
allemande
la crise des sous-marins maintenant
rabat les cartes et mettant en lumière
le partenariat stratégique entre
l'australie les états unis le royaume
uni ils ont de fait la france paris qui
ne décolère pas d'ailleurs le ministre
des affaires étrangères jean yves le
drian s'est entretenu hier avec son
homologue anthony blinken et selon
l'élysée boris johnson a proposé ce
vendredi emmanuel macron de rétablir une
coopération entre la france et le
royaume uni après la crise diplomatique
elle est sous marin une main tendue
accepté d'ailleurs par le président
français et c'est dans ce contexte
délicat que ce soir se déroule le sommet
du coi groupe de travail réunissant les
états unis l'australie l'inde et le
japon avec toujours le même but
renforcer les relations diplomatiques
dans la région indo pacifique pour
contrer la puissance de la chine dans la
région fait le point avec yanina banda
c'est un accueil chaleureux qui est
réservé au premier ministre indien ce
jeudi au pentagone derrière les mots de
bienvenue de la vice-présidente des
etats-unis kamala harris en amont de la
rencontre du quad il ne rencontre pas
comme les autres puisqu'il est question
de raviver cette alliance politique
entre l'inde l'australie le japon et les
etats-unis une initiative américaine
l'inde bien sûr est un partenaire très
important des états unis tout au long de
notre histoire nos nations ont travaillé
ensemble ont fait front commun pour
faire de notre monde un monde plus sûr
monsieur le premier ministre lors de
notre dernière conversation en juin nous
avons évoqué le fait que notre monde est
plus interconnecté et interdépendants
que jamais auparavant
et les défis auxquels nous sommes
confrontés aujourd'hui ont mis en
évidence ce fait qu'il s'agisse de kovy
19 la crise climatique et de
l'importance de notre croyance partagée
dans une région indo pacifique libre et
ouverte
officiellement la résurgence de ce
format diplomatique n'est pas avisé
militaire mais doit s'attaquer aux
nouveaux chantiers économiques
environnementaux et la lutte contre la
pandémie
des thèmes à l'ordre du jour de la
rencontre quadri latéral
excellence votre élection à la vice
présidence des états unis d'amérique
elle même a été un événement si
important et historique
vous êtes la source d'inspiration de
tant de personnes à travers le monde je
suis tout à fait convaincu que sous la
direction du président biden et de votre
leadership relations bilatérales
atteindront de nouveaux sommets
l'écologie a elle aussi été au coeur des
échanges préliminaires notamment entre
le chef d'état australien et le premier
ministre narendra modi
je reviens d'une réunion avec l'un de
mes partenaires du quad le premier
ministre maudit un ami cher et un grand
ami de l'australie nous travaillons
ensemble depuis quelques années
maintenant lors de notre réunion
d'aujourd'hui nous avons convenu d'aller
de l'avant avec un partenariat
technologique à faible émission un
partenariat qui se concentrera sur le
développement de l'hydrogène des
programmes solaire à très faible coût
afin de soutenir leur transition
énergétique
avec un tel rassemblement de dirigeants
joe biden espère renforcer ses liens
avec les quatre partenaires importants
dans la région indo pacifique
objectif faire front à la puissance
chinoise dans la région est l'une des
missions majeures restent celles de
lancer une initiative pour protéger les
approvisionnements en semi conducteurs
ces composants électroniques
indispensables tantôt machine à laver
cause avion ou aux smartphones après les
avoir rencontrés un par un le président
des états unis s'entretiendra avec les
quatre chefs d'état et aux etats-unis
toujours les images de milliers de
migrants à la frontière sud du pays
suscite la polémique encore il s'agit
notamment de ressortissants haïtiens qui
s'entassent dans des villes frontalières
près du texas une crise migratoire qui
provoque énormément de critiques
d'ailleurs contre joe biden de la droite
comme de la gauche on trouve d'ailleurs
notre correspondant à new york thomas
boni
thomas bonsoir alors comment réagir
justement la maison blanche face à cette
situation
et bien c'est une situation très
embarrassante pour la maison blanche ce
sujet parmi les sujets d'actualité les
plus discutés depuis le début de la
semaine et joe biden a été rattrapé lui
qui pensait plutôt consacré cette
semaine à la politique internationale
des états unis même lors de sa visite
ici à new york pour l'assemblée générale
des nations unies il a été interpellé
par des journalistes déjà sur cette
fameuse crise migratoire alors l'afflux
de migrants à la frontière sud des états
unis n'est pas véritablement un
phénomène nouveau cela fait maintenant
des semaines voire des mois que beaucoup
de migrants affluent en direction des
états unis mais ce qui est nouveau cette
fois c'est qu'il ya une arrivée massive
notamment de la part de ressortissants
haïtiens depuis ces derniers jours alors
selon certaines estimations il serait
14000 à être arrivé depuis le week-end
dernier notamment près de la ville de
del rio dans l'état du texas à ce jour
là encore selon des estimations 2011
ressortissants haïtiens auraient été
expulsées malgré une politique
migratoire plus flexible de la part de
l'administration de joe biden alors
cette décision d'expulser des
ressortissant haïtien a provoqué
beaucoup de critiques de la part de
militants associatifs mais surtout elle
a provoqué la démission de l'émissaire
américain en haïti dans une lettre qu'il
a publié qu'il a adressé cette semaine
au secrétaire d'état américain anthony
blinken il se montre très virulent et il
explique les raisons de son départ
écoutez
je ne m'associerai pas la décision
inhumaine et contreproductif des états
unis expulsé des milliers de réfugiés
haïtiens et d'immigrants illégaux en
haïti un pays où nos fonctionnaires sont
confinés dans des complexes sécurisé en
raison du danger que représentent les
gangs armés contrôlant la vie
quotidienne
alors à cette situation déjà très
délicate se sont ajoutés des images
impressionnantes des policiers à cheval
qui empêchent des migrants de traverser
le fleuve rio grande et la frontière
naturelle entre les etats-unis et le
mexique il ya notamment une photo d'un
garde frontières qui est donc à cheval
et qui attrape un homme par le tee shirt
et cette photo qui a beaucoup circulé
sur les réseaux sociaux notamment elle a
provoqué beaucoup d'émoi des images
elles saisissante qui ont nourri les
critiques pendant ces derniers jours si
bien que joe biden qui dit ce vendredi
en assumer la pleine responsabilité
affirme aussi que des sanctions vont
être prises contre ces officiers de
police écouter
du sort c'est horrible de voir comme
vous l'avez vu de voir les gens traités
ainsi les chevaux en train de les
écraser les gens étant attachés
c'est scandaleux je vous le promets ces
gens vont payer il y aura une enquête il
y aura des conséquences il y aura des
conséquences mais c'est plus qu'un
embarras c'est dangereux c'est une
erreur ça envoie le mauvais message au
monde entier ce envoie le mauvais
message chez nous ce n'est tout
simplement pas qui nous sommes
et la décision a donc été prise pour le
moment de cesser l'utilisation de
policiers à cheval pour gérer l'afflux
donc de migrants près de la ville de à
del rio sur la question de l'immigration
plus généralement l'administration de
joe biden joue les funambules parce que
d'un côté elle veut faire preuve de
fermeté et d'ailleurs elle a même
envisagé pendant un temps selon des
médias américains d'ouvrir un centre de
transit à guantanamo pour y héberger des
ressortissants haïtiens en attente d'une
décision sur leur possibilité ou non
d'entrer sur le territoire américain et
puis de l'autre côté à l'administration
d'autres biden a permis à des milliers
de ressortissants haïtiens justement
d'entrer aux états unis alors quoi qu'il
arrive la gestion de cette crise
migratoire est très critiqué la droite
reproche à joe biden son laxisme et la
gauche condamne elle le traitement jugé
inhumain de ces réfugiés maintenant
beaucoup réclament que joe biden se
rendent sur place en personne alors que
cette crise migratoire justement un
impact non négligeable sur la popularité
du président merci beaucoup avoue thomas
bonnet pour toute cette précision est de
3 pour les états unis ce vendredi joe
biden a autorisé une troisième dose de
vaccin sont visés les personnes âgées
celles considérées à risque ou encore
celles exposées au coût de 19 dans leur
travail comme les enseignants ou encore
les employés de supermarchés aux
autorités de santé américaines ont donné
leur feu vert 24 heures seulement après
avoir émis un avis contraire
et puis ce nouveau record de décès dus
aux convives 19 en russie cette fois
plus de 800 personnes sont mortes ces
dernières 24 heures les autorités
pointent le faible taux de personnes
vaccinées les détails c'est avec notre
correspondant à moscou en train de
clairoix
la russie a enregistré ce vendredi un
nouveau record de décès quotidiens 828
personnes ont trouvé la mort en raison
du coc u19 ces dernières 24 heures le
dernier record qui s'élevait à 8 120
décès avait été atteint à deux reprises
tout récemment encore les 26 août et 23
septembre dernier moscou et saint
pétersbourg reste les villes les plus
touchées par la pandémie tandis que la
vaccination ne décolle toujours pas à
l'heure actuelle seuls 28,4 pour cent de
la population russe est entièrement
vacciner devenir poutine pour sa part
est toujours à l' isolement après
l'annnonce de plusieurs cas de co vide
dans son entourage son porte parole a
ajouté que de nouveaux cas continuer
d'être découvert au sein du kremlin tout
en assurant que des mesures étaient
prises pour empêcher leur propagation
le break site serait-il à l'origine de
pénurie d'essence au royaume uni c'est
ce que pensent les automobilistes à
londres ce dernier constate que depuis
la sortie du pays de l'union européenne
y devient compliqué de s'approvisionner
en essence pas uniquement d'ailleurs de
son côté le ministre des transports
britannique grant shapps sa tente de
rassurer la population en minimisant le
nombre de stations impact est pas sûr
que cela suffise à calmer les
inquiétudes écouter quelques réactions à
la sortie d'une station service
tout cela remonte aux briques site
depuis le break site il ya une pénurie
de main d'oeuvre dans toutes les
industries cela aurait dû être pensé
mais ce gouvernement n'a jamais pensé à
l'avenir et ils se contentent de réagir
à un problème au lieu de réfléchir à ce
que sont les problèmes et d'essayer de
penser à une solution
il parlait d'une pénurie de chauffeurs
ou quelque chose comme ça mais je suis
vraiment désespérée et je ne sais pas où
aller ensuite
c'est un peu gênant c'est gênant comme
si nous vivions dans un pays du tiers
monde ou quelque chose comme ça
le premier ministre libanais najib
mikati et le président emmanuel macron
se sont entretenus en début d'après midi
les deux hommes au diapason sur la
nécessité pour le liban donné des
réformes au plus vite le pays est englué
dans une crise importante et son
économie est au bord de l'effondrement
je vous propose d'écouter les deux
hommes à l'issue de leur déjeuner de
travail
la france a toujours a toujours été et
continuent d'être l'allié
indéfectible de mon pays
récemment le liban a été frappé par
l'industrie de crestron que l'on plongé
étant l'une des plus graves crises de
son histoire
dans cette épreuve monsieur le président
vous avez été à nos côtés soyons lucides
le chemin sera difficile mais pas au
delà de ces sujets nous savons les
réformes d'ampleur
sur le système financier et bancaire
comme sur les sujets de gouvernance et
je crois que nous partageons la même
lucidité sur l'ambition des réformes
qu'il ya devant nous mais comme vous
venez de le dire
ce chemin n'est pas impossible nous
connaissons la feuille de route elle
reste la même et nous savons aussi
l'urgence d'une situation qui est
devenue humanitaire et que vous avez
aujourd'hui à gérer
j'ai eu les dix à beyrouth et je le
redis je le répète ici à vos côtés je ne
lâche pas le liban
et la france ne laissera pas libre
ces entretiens ne suffiront pas à
remettre le liban sur pied selon à
mounir à douma ni les membres du parti
libanais citoyens et citoyennes dans un
état on écoute la france pense avoir
marqué des points elle n'a réussi à
mettre au moins un pion de plus au
moyen-orient bien sûr avec l'accord de
l'iran des etats-unis etc il ya un terme
qui a utilisé par un bar emmanuel macron
qui est il a parlé de feuille de route
d'accord il en parle depuis un bout de
temps cette feuille de route personne
n'était au courant de ce qu'elle
contient que le nouveau gouvernement
dans sa déclaration de politique
générale à a dit que nous allons
implémenter les politiques que tout le
monde aujourd'hui connaît nous allons
implémenter les répudier réforme
desquelles tout le monde est au courant
alors bon je ne sais pas de quoi il
parle personne est au courant de ces
choses aujourd'hui ce qui s'est passé ne
répond pas aux aspirations des libanais
aujourd'hui les aspirations des libanais
sont les suivantes nous sommes nous
sommes dans une situation où le pays est
en faillite nous n'entrons pas dans une
crise économique nous sommes dans
l'effondrement économique
ce pays est sur le point d'être liquidée
en tunisie rached ghannouchi le leader
du parti islamiste ennahda appelle à
lutter contre les pouvoirs d'un seul
homme une réaction à la suite de la
promulgation mercredi par le président
kaïs aide de dispositions renforçant ses
prérogatives et cela à deux mois après
la suspension par le chef de l'état du
parlement au nom de la lutte anti
corruption allez précision avec notre
correspondant à tunis bassam chili c'est
un retour en arrière vers le règne
absolu d'un seul homme cette référence à
l'ère ben ali est signée rached
ghannouchi chef du parlement et de la
première formation politique du pays
chez le parti islamiste ennahda lors
d'une interview accordée hier à nos
confrères de l' agence france-presse
l'homme de 80 ans auquel le chef de
l'état a retiré mercredi tous les
privilèges inhérents à sa fonction n'a
pas hésité à appeler la population à
s'unir pacifiquement contre le cas ici a
été écouté
c'est un retour en arrière un retour à
la constitution de 1959 le retour vers
le pouvoir absolu d'un seul homme contre
lequel la révolution a eu lieu
la seule option aujourd'hui la lutte
naturellement la lutte pacifique car
nous sommes un mouvement civil le peuple
tunisien et contre la violence
nous espérons que les narda les autres
partis et la société civile vont se
battre pour récupérer leur constitution
et leur démocratie
deux mois après son coup de force
locataire du palais de carthage a
détaillé via la page facebook de la
présidence de la république les contours
de sa feuille de route tant attendu les
mesures d'exception sont prolongées
l'assemblée des représentants du peuple
reste gelé l'immunité des parlementaires
toujours lever et leurs salaires
suspendus le chef de l'état légiférera
désormais par décret pour une durée
indéterminée il n'en fallait pas moins
pour susciter la colère du parti
islamiste et l'inquiétude la classe
politique tunisienne dans son ensemble
dont une partie s'était pourtant montré
favorable à l'action présidentielle du
25 juillet dernier dans un communiqué
conjoint publié jeudi quatre partis
politiques de tous bords ont appelé à
mettre fin ce qu'il qualifie désormais
de coup d'état le président sayed ayant
perdu sa légitimité en violant la
constitution selon eux malgré la colère
des magistrats de la société civile de
la classe politique l'homme fort du pays
semble plus que jamais déterminée à
poursuivre son projet pour la tunisie
faisant filles de toute menace est mise
en garde
dans l'actualité ces manifestations en
afghanistan maintenant plusieurs
centaines de personnes se sont réunies
ce vendredi dans les rues de kaboul pour
protester contre le gel des avoirs par à
la pompe centrale un montant estimé à 7
milliards de dollars et ils réclament
que cet argent bloqué par les américains
depuis la fin de la prise de pouvoir des
talibans soient disponibles pour éviter
une crise économique de plus grande
ampleur écouter ces témoignages
[Musique]
nous sommes réunis ici pour protester
contre le gel des avoirs afghans par les
banques américaines nous voulons que ces
actifs soit libéré ses actifs et cet
argent appartient au peuple afghan il
n'appartient pas aux talibans
il devrait entendre notre voix et elle
devrait mettre à l'ordre du jour cette
question à l'agenda des nations unies et
dans de nombreux autres réunions il
devrait dès que possible des bloquer ces
avoirs pour ne pas faire face à une
crise économique à l'avenir
elle reste de l'actualité internationale
en bref et en images en bolivie à des
manifestants blessés et d'autres arrêtés
lors d'affrontements entre des groupes
opposés de producteurs de coca et la
police c'était ce jeudi donc à la base
chaque groupe assure détenir le contrôle
du marché local de feuilles de coca là
la vente de feuilles de coca est un
business légale dans le pays selon
l'office des nations unies contre la
drogue et le crime la bolivie un
excédent de culture de coca d'environ
dix neuf mille hectares
des heures en cisjordanie entre des
manifestants et palestiniens et des
troupes aux israéliens et ont éclaté
donc ce jeudi des incidents en marge
d'une manifestation qui a entraîné la
mort d'un palestinien est la ville de
bêta où se sont déroulés les faits est
devenu un point chaud ces derniers mois
ce genre d'ami es les habitants et
organise à chaque semaine des
manifestations contre la colonisation
israélienne
retour en france avec un procès très
suivi celui des attentats du 13 novembre
qui ont touché paris et sa proche
banlieue aujourd'hui à la cour s'est
penchée sur l'adn à des terroristes
leurs explosifs et la propagande des
troupes terroristes ont fait le point
depuis la cour d'assises spéciale de
paris avec notre reporter katia
technique aujourd'hui une vidéo a été
projetée dans laquelle on a pu voir 9
protagonistes en action majoritairement
en syrie du commando du 13 novembre
un point a été fait par un agent de la
sous direction antiterroriste sur la
propagande sophistiqué de l'état
islamique à l'époque notamment avec la
revendication des frères fabien et jean
michel klein que le chef de l'état
islamique à l'époque al bagdadi avait
qualifié de chevalier des médias ils
sont présumés morts en syrie en 2019
dans les bombardements contre l'état
islamique eh bien ce sont eux qui
avaient enregistré le message de
revendication des attentats du 13
novembre
diffusée dès le lendemain suivi pendant
plusieurs mois de diffusion de vidéos
dommages aux terroristes et d'autres
annonçant des attentats à venir nous
avons donc pu entendre cet extrait audio
guerrier dans lequel il parle de
ceintures d'explosifs
deux pays de croiser de françois
hollande qui l'ont rebaptisé pour
l'occasion un imbécile de france de
centaines didot lettres dans une fête de
perversité au stade de france avec des
incitations à tuer les croisés puis est
venue cette vidéo insoutenable de
propagande même si les moments les plus
sanglants avaient été supprimés c'était
épouvantable à boire elle avait été
diffusée sur les réseaux le 24 janvier
2016 après que tous les terroristes ont
été identifiés et un slogan revient en
permanence tuez les où que vous les
retrouves y est on y voit neuf membres
du commando du 13 novembre dont
abdelhamid about ils sont habillés en
militaires promettent aux croisés toutes
sortes de tortures et de tourments
couteau en main il décapite chacun un
otage habillés en orange sept en tout
tout cela montre la préparation
minutieuse de l'opération et l'ambition
de semer la terreur de l'organisation au
plus fort de sa puissance puisqu'elle ne
subsiste aujourd'hui qu'à l'état de
cellules et c'est la fin de cette
édition merci à vous de l'avoir suivi on
va se retrouver en direct dans une
trentaine de minutes reste avec nous sur
rt france
[Musique]
et
y'a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple c'était
une volonté collectés vous le savez pour
moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y a pas
d'alternative on sort du pays il est
clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez des sous le
numéro i l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï tg les gens ne
s'étaient des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent saison qu'il
avait envie de transmettre quelque chose
à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer qu une
sixième république qui ne soit pas la
double hic parlementaire ça se passe en
direct puisque on est en direct il y a
quand même la liberté je vous remercie
de m'avoir invité
[Musique]